it's a perennial trick question
what's the deadliest animal on earth the
answer is not crocodiles or snakes and
certainly not sharks far and away the
creature most responsible for human
suffering is the mosquito the World
Health Organization estimates that the
spread of malaria dengue and yellow
fever by mosquitoes results in several
million deaths a year in the United
States mosquitoes have caused almost
40,000 cases of the West Nile virus
since 1999 just last year several cases
of the chikungunya virus turned up in
Florida for the first time ever the
painful infection is spread by invasive
species like the Asian tiger mosquito
which wasn't even present in the US
until 1985 which leads to a question
you've probably asked yourself if
mosquitoes are such a danger why don't
we just kill them all why do they even
exist put that to a mosquito researcher
and you're likely to get a dismissive
laugh they've heard this before first
I'll tell you it's hard to predict the
ecological effect of killing off
mosquitoes two entomologist told us
they're unaware of any species that
relies solely on mosquitoes for food but
that's not to say there would be no
unforeseen consequences to wiping them
out plus the kill them all we'd have to
do some serious damage to their habitats
with its own untold effects and besides
there'd be no point of the 3,000 or so
mosquito species worldwide only a couple
dozen spread disease to humans many
don't bite people at all and as our
researchers pointed out any two species
of mosquito can be as different as a
hummingbird and a bald eagle why would
we try to target all those species with
a single blow so give up your dream of a
mosquito free world for a more realistic
goal how do we at least get rid of those
species that are a real threat now we're
talking the textbook method calls for
environmental steps like draining creeks
to make conditions unfavorable the
mosquitoes then the use of larvacide to
target the young of problem species you
can go after adults with certain
pesticides if necessary but many more
cutting-edge approaches are in the works
one described by University of Kentucky
researcher employs what he called the
mosquito birth control
his technique involves bacteria called
Wolbachia which lives in many of the
world's insects in mosquitoes males and
females infected with the bacteria must
have the exact same strain to reproduce
successfully researchers can use this
knowledge to introduce multiple strains
and effectively sterilize males
hence mosquito birth control this may
not create a world free of smacking your
neck and spraying yourself with
chemicals when mosquito season strikes
but eliminating the two dozen species
that spark human disease would be one of
the greatest public health victories in
history